in this portion of our world views and
values class we're going to look at they
work by the philosopher jean-jacques
rousseau a great social theorist and
thinker who wrote in French but was not
actually from France originally and the
work that we're going to look at is
called the discourse on the origin of
inequalities among human beings
sometimes the last part is translated as
humanity or among man any of them are
perfectly good translations now as usual
with this sort of introductory video
we're going to try to cover three main
things to help you get ready to plow
into this work one thing that we're
going to talk about is the literary
genre of this work and what you should
be looking out for because of that
another thing that we'll talk about
that's very important I think for this
work is historical context situating
Rousseau and his ideas in this
particular text within a historical
milieu and even moment and then the last
thing that we'll talk about are some of
the key themes in outline that you
should be paying particular attention to
what does it help to know about the
genre of the discourse on inequality so
first off we're looking at something
that's called the discourse and in
philosophy that's a word that gets used
for some sort of systematic
investigation not necessarily trying to
you know completely go through a topic
or a matter in an exhaustive
comprehensive manner but certainly
focusing in particularly important
aspects of it and here the discourse is
on inequality so we're so wants to
explain the nature and the development
of inequality you can think of this as
an extended essay it's how it has one
very long many parts all put together a
kind of argument going on and you have
to do a bit of work in order to
reconstruct the entire structure of the
work and see the argument for
what it is but there is a coherent
narrative or argument underlying this
whole thing now one other thing that's
important to think about what is he
trying to do in this when you're first
reading it you might say well he's
trying to do what we nowadays call
history or anthropology or ethnography
and Rousseau isn't exactly making claims
that you know his the story that he's
telling is historically accurate in
every single case that it covers every
single civilization he's trying to
suggest to us that what we take for
granted in civilization the ideas the
technology the environment the social
relations that to us seem quite natural
aren't really natural that they are the
products of the historical development a
long process of development so what he's
doing is he's reconstructing a narrative
of you can call a progress if you want
development is probably a better word
for it because progress often has this
this sense of being you know from better
- better to better and he's carrying out
what we call a genealogical account he's
trying to say that we can trace out the
origins in general not not into great
specificity but in general some of the
things that in the present or at least
in the present of the 18th century that
he's writing we take as being just you
know going without saying or or things
that are obviously the case so a
genealogical account is trying to trace
things back to their Genesis to their
origin and then follow out the process
to show that things didn't necessarily
have to go the way that they did
certainly not when we get down to the
level of particular x' so Rousseau is is
aiming at showing the development of the
human being from our animal origins
although a little bit different than
other
in certain respects all the way up to
the the heights of civilization now he's
also trying to make a point through this
he's carrying out evaluations that's
another key term to think of that he's
trying to say that there were certain
stages of development and he's wondering
whether we're actually better off
through all of these processes that
we've gone through or whether human
beings were better off in earlier stages
and you're gonna see him making some
arguments about you know how this is
gone he'll actually say that with
civilization a lot of bad things came
some really good things came at the bad
things tend to outweigh the good so
that's that's the the master argument
there he is engaging some other previous
theorists in particular Thomas Hobbes
although he also brings up a couple
other people like John Locke and puffin
Dorf and a few other people as well the
the main if there's only one person to
think about that you would want to read
in order to understand some of what he's
reacting against I think it would be
Thomas Hobbes and you would want to read
Leviathan because that was his most
influential work now there's other
things to tell you about this work that
I think helped to put it into a bit of
context as well and now we're starting
to get a little bit closer
to historical context this was in fact a
essay that was submitted to a prize
competition that we still have these
sort of competitions going on today by
the way and academies and learning
journals in what we call the Republic of
Letters would every once in a while
offer a prize and they would say here's
a question we want everybody to write an
essay in response to this and the best
essay will get a prize you know some
money and you'll get known this will be
a way in which you acquire reputation as
the thinker as an author and will also
publish your piece in our our journal so
Rousseau had done this before with his
discourse on the Arts
Sciences in the same contest he's doing
this a little bit later four years later
with the or the discourse on the origin
of inequality and it was the academy of
dijon dijon is a city in france they had
a university there and the economy is is
offering this prize and if you if you
won you would be published in the
Mercure de france which was a great
prestigious journal at that time so
Rousseau writes this piece not just to
you know publish it somewhere not just
because he's interested in this but
because it's occasioned somebody asks a
question about the origin of inequality
and how that has to do with natural law
and so this is Russo's answer to that we
can read it on on our own without having
to think about these sorts of background
things but it's kind of useful to know
that and it kind of fits into Russo's
larger project so if you were going to
go on and read more Rousseau you would
want to read his other discourse the
discourse on the Arts and Sciences and
he would definitely want to read the
work the social contract which he is is
referencing the idea of in this work
some other works by Rousseau that
probably would be germane to this would
be the the amel which has to do with the
notion of Education and also Rousseau's
confessions which which give you an idea
about his development as an author
there's a lot to say about the
historical context that this work finds
itself within we're now midway into the
period that we call modernity
we're just decades away from the French
Revolution the somewhat earlier and
somewhat less earth-shaking American
Revolution as well it's a time of great
change it's also a time of massive
massive inequalities and inefficiencies
in this developing European civilization
so there's a number of different points
that we want to run through very quickly
just to give you kind of a
panoramic view of the situation in which
was so is writing and also the situation
that he is going to be influencing so
these we're talking about somebody who
is writing in the matrix of a highly
developed highly evolved and at the same
time in many ways still overlaid on on
primitive basis European society and
he's writing in French at the time when
if you want to talk about two main
rivals for the culture of Europe for the
dominant power not only economically and
militarily but in terms of just you know
what we nowadays call soft power
cultural power it would be England and
France and Rousseau lived in both of
those places
he didn't understand English didn't have
a good time in England and we'll talk
about that a little bit later but he had
a massive role within these cultures in
part because he is a cultural critic he
is looking at these cultures almost as
an outsider almost as somebody who
doesn't identify with them but who can
see what's going on in them better than
the people who are living in them and
can bring to life their inconsistencies
and their flaws so we have a culture
that's able to generate immense wealth
but the wealth is not being shared
fairly or you know according to any sort
of norms of equality opportunities are
open you know to those who can seize
them and the vast majority of people are
living in states of quite miserable
conditions so we have a time of great
contradictions and great opportunities I
think that you could talk about three
e's that that sort of succeed each other
and interpenetrate with each other that
also tinge this this civilization on the
one hand we're talking about an era of
exploration the Europeans because of
their
of you know new techniques of navigation
new shipbuilding the the economic
wherewithal the put you know expeditions
out there they have by now begun to
circumnavigate the the entire globe and
start to fill in a lot of blank spaces
on the maps and this you know resulted
in a lot of conflicts and clashes
between European settlers or colonists
or explorers or even conquistadors and
native peoples indigenous peoples
throughout the world that they were
running into and also the older
civilizations that you know the the
original explorers were trying to reach
like in India and China it was a time in
which Europeans were becoming more and
more dominant in part because of their
technology and part because of their
greatly increasing numbers which which
was a factor of technology as well
disease played a part in that there were
areas which became rapidly depopulated
in the Americas because of their
exposure to European illnesses that
Europeans had Europeans and the Asians
had resistance to so the the Age of
Exploration leads into an age of
exploitation and the Europeans with some
exceptions some very important
exceptions didn't treat indigenous
peoples very well they superimposed you
know what they conceived of as natural
European norms on to them sometimes with
some success sometimes not there were a
lot of prospects you know of
colonization and trying to extract
resources from from lands and from
people so there's a lot of exploitation
going on the you know hierarchy or class
system becomes established in many areas
that hadn't had that before or which had
other kinds of societies which were
quite developed and had quite strong
hierarchies as well but they were
replaced by a year of hands and their
successors it was also a time of empire
so we're talking about you know a French
Empire and a British Empire
you know vast Holdings all over the
places an expansion going on now like I
said there were some great inequalities
running throughout this society and and
if we can think of inequalities of just
every sort of a manner inequalities of
wealth inequalities of opportunity
inequalities of education most people
didn't have any access to education at
that time property power rank some of
these inequalities were also seen as on
the one hand by those who possess them
being you know as part of the natural
order or the way things should be and by
people who are suffering under them as
being totally arbitrary being unfair
having no good reason to be there so you
have a lot of social conflict and social
tension going on within this society
there were a lot of people carrying out
investigations in in philosophy and also
in what we would nowadays call
anthropology or ethnography try to think
about how the situation of human beings
had gone from you know whatever the
original state of human beings was to
the condition that we're in today they
were very interested in developmental
sort of quasi historical reconstructions
of the the ongoing progress of human
beings some people were thinking about
this in religious manners but because of
the rise of modern science and because
there was this tendency to explain
things less and less in terms of
religion and more and more in terms of
you know what we could observe
empirically or what we could theorize
what
the human mind there's a greater
tendency to want to to try to strip
those elements away and say no we should
begin from a naturalistic perspective we
should try to understand the human being
in their development all the way up to
the present time coming from animal
origins all the way to civilized human
beings and we're so is writing in a
context where other people are going
doing this he thinks he can do one
better on them so another thing that we
can talk about in terms of historical
context is particularly for jean-jacques
Rousseau the contrast between Geneva the
town that he is growing up in a Swiss
canton a essentially city state which is
originally fairly democratic although
it's also you know run by by by what we
would nowadays see is pretty hardcore
religious elements the Calvinists and
the contrast between Geneva and Paris
Rousseau is going to grow up in Geneva
so you know we we see a similar thing to
like what happens when the small town
person goes to the great metropolis and
they lose some of their naivete and they
start to say you know their little small
town people they were kind of restricted
in their ideas and the attitudes but
then after a while they start to say you
know there was a lot of stuff that I
kind of liked about the small town
that's just not there in the big city
the big city is kind of soulless
heartless it takes people in and grinds
them up chews them up spits them out
uses them so Rousseau is going to be
critical actually of both of these polls
but it's something worth worth keeping
in mind if you're going to do any
further research in them you'll see how
important these these conceptions are
now one of the other things that I
really want to talk about is the
intellectual development within the year
Kian sphere which also extends to the
Americas in certain respects as well we
can speak of what we what they like to
call back then a Republic of Letters and
what we mean there is not just letters
circulating back and forth as if
everybody was emailing each other using
paper a piss epistolary literature you
know the kind of literature that comes
from writing letters to people was an
important element of that we see for
example Montesquieu with his Persian
letters or Volterra's letters playing an
important role but what we're talking
about is the growth of an intellectual
class within society largely among the
growing bourgeoisie the upper middle
class the property owners the people who
had businesses that sort of thing and
the middle class now there were a lot of
different elements to this some people
talk about this like you're gonna hammer
Moscow talks about the development of a
public sphere the idea was that instead
of the the aristocrats the the nobles or
the clergy essentially dominating the
intellectual scene it now becomes those
who are willing to communicate through
writing those who will engage each other
those who read each other's writing who
read the latest reviews who read the
latest journals and there were a number
of different supports to this some of it
was face to face in what they called
salons you know and in the coffee houses
in the cafes all of this is part of the
environment that Rousseau is quite at
home in in many respects a guy like
Rousseau probably and in some ways could
not have made it as big without that
that sounding board of the Republic of
Letters within which his works could
could reverberate and it offers him the
opportunities to come into contact with
and even develop friendships
with some very important thinkers like
Diderot who invites him along with
Dalembert to work on the encyclopedia
one of the very first encyclopedia
projects also David Hume the the
Scottish philosopher who also is known
for his literary and historical works at
that time who brings Rousseau over to
England for a while until Rousseau gets
a little nuts accuses David Hume
plotting against him and basically turns
a guy who is one of the most sanguine
and easy to get along with people in the
world into somebody who says you got to
get out of here but the point is
Rousseau is able to come into contact
with these these brilliant thinkers he's
also able to get the notice of people
who will criticize him like Voltaire and
you know they say there's no there's no
bad publicity I think in the sense of
you know of the kind of work that we're
so is doing that's probably a true thing
the more that people would criticize him
the more that people would read him
Rousseau along with some of these other
people became what we can call some of
the banned bestsellers of that era
because at the same time as conceptions
of freedom and and you know getting away
from old forms of government and and
thinking and approaches to the world and
to the human person that are rooted in
tradition or rooted in superstition
along with all that comes a clamping
down by the powers that be on
revolutionary thoughts and Rousseau
really is a revolutionary thinker we
should mention that one of the the major
effects of Russo's work is in fact the
French Revolution it would be a mistake
to attribute it entirely to roussel but
he certainly it plays a major role in
Fanning the intellectual flames that
will you know exploit the the the
inequalities and the great miseries of
human being to eventually produce a
revolution that says we're
just try to reform things we're gonna
sweep things away and begin on totally
new grounds Rousseau is one of these
people who is called the filosophy the
revolutionaries took him as being a hero
because of his emphasis on human beings
in the state of nature on the role that
compassion or sympathy would play and on
primitive societies Rousseau is also to
be credited for helping to spur the
growing Romantic movement as well in
literature in philosophy and also even
in music he was a person who wrote some
musical pieces and had great interest in
music as well so you noticed that again
as with most of the figures that were
reading
not only is Rousseau being formed by and
and assuming is important because of the
context that he's in he's also going to
be steering it to a certain degree as
well what are some of the key ideas some
of the key concepts that you should be
on the lookout for as we go through this
work so there's quite a few of them one
of these is the state of nature and
Rousseau will actually talk about a
primitive state of nature which he
thinks is quite different than the state
of nature is depicted by other social
theorists and then a corrupt state of
nature that he thinks answers to what
people like Hobbes are talking about so
that's going to be an important thing to
pay attention to moving past the state
of nature we get to another key idea
which is that of primitive civilizations
or as he's going to call them savage or
barbarian civilizations or cultures and
he thinks that this is one important
stage of development on the way to human
civilizations of the modern European
code so a third important thing to think
about
a third important idea would be the
state of civilized society the kind of
society that they lived in in the 18th
century and which we live in a successor
society to today which I think Rousseau
would say we have a lot of the same
issues and problems going on now another
thing that's key to this that allows you
to actually move from one to the other
is this notion of self improvement or
progress or development as being
integral to the human being another word
that you'll use that you'll see used for
this is human perfection or becoming
more and more perfect in older
literature and the idea that Rousseau
has is that this is something that sets
us apart from the other animals and we
do this partly by changing ourselves but
also by surrounding ourselves with all
kinds of Technology and culture and
social relations
another thing that he's going to talk
about that's very important a type of
technology that we often don't think of
this technology is language he will
spend quite a bit of time discussing the
origins of language and the role that
language plays in allowing us to
articulate ideas to form new conceptions
to become more and more what human
beings look like today another key idea
that you'll want to pay close attention
to Rousseau thinks that human beings are
not fundamentally different from the
animals by having ideas or being able to
think but by developing that but that
actually happens through development of
the passions the emotions will play an
incredibly important role or the
emotions the desires our whole panoply
effectivity plays an important role in
how we think about things for Rousseau
now one of the most important ones that
he's going to talk about and really
stress here something that's available
to human beings in the state of nature
but becomes so
what anaemic in civilized society is
what he calls compassion another word
for this that was very popular at the
time was sympathy
Rousseau thinks that we have an
instinctive compassion for other human
beings we don't want them to suffer we
don't want them to be threatened we want
to take care of those who are vulnerable
but that that's something that although
it's instinctual to us we can we can
wipe out and he thinks that civilization
actually does quite a number on us in
expunging that from from our way of
being another key idea that that comes
along is that of property and of law as
being a protector of property primarily
now that brings us to the notion of
inequality and this entire discourse is
supposed to be tracing out the
development of inequality where did it
come from how did it develop how did it
become worse and worse and worse and
Rousseau is going to diagnose a number
of different causes and a number of
different effects that inequality has in
order for us to understand it's it's its
workings another key idea that you
should pay attention to the incredible
transformative role of Agriculture and
metallurgy in taking us from primitive
societies that are based around what
he's calling morality and moving us
toward civilizations that are based on
notions of property and law the very
understanding of morality as something
that arises in primitive societies out
of the human tendency to compare
ourselves with others once we've become
settled in in abodes with them in in a
way of life a shared way of life the the
notion of primitive morality or of codes
of morality is something that's that's
very important finally we have this
notion of social contract which is not
going to explore in great
detail here but does play a role in in
is thinking the the basic idea behind
social contract is that human beings in
a society are all in one sort of
fundamental basic agreement that is
expressed in a general will not the will
of one person but the will of the whole
society and that will you know sort of
specifies how we ought to behave towards
each other the very last thing that this
leads to which is going to spur even
more and more inequality in society it
is what he calls magistracy or we can
call it government and Russo's idea is
that once we're gonna civilize society
and we have laws and we have a social
contract we need some sort of agency
which will make sure that the contract
is actually followed unfortunately that
agency tends to attract more and more
power to itself it becomes instead of
being a servant of the people it becomes
the people's master and imposes
servitude upon them and this leads to
inequalities that that tend to be
perpetuated inequalities of wealth
inequalities of power inequalities of
prestige inequalities of opportunity
inequalities of all different sorts and
so that is inherent in his notion of
what he calls magister C so those are
the key ideas now I think you're ready
to dig into the text